for hundreds of years analog computers
were the most powerful computers on
earth predicting eclipses tides and
guiding anti-aircraft guns then with the
advent of solid-state transistors
digital computers took off now virtually
every computer we use is digital
but today
a perfect storm of factors is setting
the scene for a resurgence of analog
technology
this is an analog computer and by
connecting these wires in particular
ways i can program it to solve a whole
range of differential equations
for example this setup allows me to
simulate a damped mass oscillating on a
spring so on the oscilloscope you can
actually see the position of the mass
over time
and i can vary the damping
or the spring constant
or the mass and we can see how the
amplitude and duration of the
oscillations change
now what makes this an analog computer
is that there are no zeros and ones in
here instead there's actually a voltage
that oscillates up and down exactly like
a mass on a spring the electrical
circuitry is an analog for the physical
problem it just takes place much faster
now if i change the electrical
connections i can program this computer
to solve other differential equations
like the lorentz system which is a basic
model of convection in the atmosphere
now the laurent system is famous because
it was one of the first discovered
examples of chaos and here you can see
the lorentz attractor with its beautiful
butterfly shape
and on this analog computer i can change
the parameters and see their effects in
real time
so these examples illustrate some of the
advantages of analog computers they are
incredibly powerful computing devices
and they can complete a lot of
computations fast plus they don't take
much power to do it
with a digital computer if you want to
add two 8-bit numbers you need around 50
transistors whereas with an analog
computer you can add two currents
just by connecting
two wires
with a digital computer to multiply two
numbers you need on the order of a
thousand transistors all switching zeros
and ones whereas with an analog computer
you can pass a current
through a resistor
and then the voltage across this
resistor
will be i times r
so effectively you have multiplied
two numbers together
but analog computers also have their
drawbacks for one thing they are not
general purpose computing devices i mean
you're not going to run microsoft word
on this thing and also since the inputs
and outputs are continuous i can't input
exact values so if i try to repeat the
same calculation i'm never going to get
the exact same answer plus think about
manufacturing analog computers there's
always going to be some variation in the
exact value of components like resistors
or capacitors so as a general rule of
thumb you can expect about a one percent
error so when you think of analog
computers you can think powerful fast
and energy efficient but also
single purpose non-repeatable and
inexact
and if those sound like deal breakers
it's because they probably are i think
these are the major reasons why analog
computers fell out of favor as soon as
digital computers became viable
now here's why analog computers may be
making a comeback
[Music]
it all starts with artificial
intelligence a machine has been
programmed to see and to move objects
ai isn't new the term was coined back in
1956. in 1958 cornell university
psychologist frank rosenblatt built the
perceptron designed to mimic how neurons
fire in our brains
so here's a basic model of how neurons
in our brains work an individual neuron
can either fire or not so its level of
activation can be represented as a one
or a zero
the input to one neuron is the output
from a bunch of other neurons but the
strength of these connections between
neurons varies so each one can be given
a different weight
some connections are excitatory so they
have positive weights while others are
inhibitory so they have negative weights
and the way to figure out whether a
particular neuron fires is to take the
activation of each input neuron and
multiply by its weight
and then add these all together if their
sum is greater than some number called
the bias then the neuron fires but if
it's less than that the neuron doesn't
fire
as input rosenblatt's perceptron had 400
photocells arranged in a square grid to
capture a 20 by 20 pixel image you can
think of each pixel as an input neuron
with its activation being the brightness
of the pixel
although strictly speaking the
activation should be either 0 or 1 we
can let it take any value between 0 and
1.
all of these neurons are connected to a
single output neuron each via its own
adjustable weight
so to see if the output neuron will fire
you multiply the activation of each
neuron by its weight and add them
together
this is essentially a vector dot product
if the answer is larger than the bias
the neuron fires and if not it doesn't
now the goal of the perceptron was to
reliably distinguish between two images
like a rectangle and a circle for
example the output neuron could always
fire when presented with a circle but
never when presented with a rectangle
to achieve this the perceptron had to be
trained that is shown a series of
different circles and rectangles and
have its weights adjusted accordingly
we can visualize the weights as an image
since there's a unique weight for each
pixel of the image
initially rosenblatt set all the weights
to zero if the perceptron's output is
correct for example here it's shown a
rectangle and the output neuron doesn't
fire no change is made to the weights
but if it's wrong then the weights are
adjusted the algorithm for updating the
weights is remarkably simple here the
output neuron didn't fire when it was
supposed to because it was shown a
circle so to modify the weights you
simply add the input activations to the
weights
if the output neuron fires when it
shouldn't like here when shown a
rectangle well then you subtract the
input activations from the weights
and you keep doing this until the
perceptron correctly identifies all the
training images it was shown that this
algorithm will always converge so long
as it's possible to map the two
categories into distinct groups
the perceptron was capable of
distinguishing between different shapes
like rectangles and triangles or between
different letters and according to
rosenblatt it could even tell the
difference between cats and dogs
he said the machine was capable of what
amounts to original thought
and the media lapped it up the new york
times called the perceptron the embryo
of an electronic computer that the navy
expects will be able to walk talk see
write reproduce itself and be conscious
of its existence
after training on lots of examples it's
given new faces it has never seen and is
able to successfully distinguish male
from females
it has learned
in reality the perceptron was pretty
limited in what it could do it could not
in fact tell apart dogs from cats this
and other critiques were raised in a
book by mit giants minsky and papert in
1969. and that led to a bust period for
artificial neural networks and ai in
general it's known as the first ai
winter
rosenblatt did not survive this winter
he drowned while sailing in chesapeake
bay on his 43rd birthday
[Music]
the nav lab is a road worthy truck
modified so that researchers or
computers can control the vehicle as
occasion demands in the 1980s there was
an ai resurgence when researchers at
carnegie mellon created one of the first
self-driving cars
the vehicle was steered by an artificial
neural network called alvin
it was similar to the perceptron except
it had a hidden layer of artificial
neurons between the input and output
as input alvin received 30 by 32 pixel
images of the road ahead here i'm
showing them as 60 by 64 pixels but each
of these input neurons was connected via
an adjustable weight to a hidden layer
of four neurons these were each
connected to 32 output neurons so to go
from one layer of the network to the
next you perform a matrix multiplication
the input activation times the weights
the output neuron with the greatest
activation determines the steering angle
to train the neural net a human drove
the vehicle providing the correct
steering angle for a given input image
all the weights in the neural network
were adjusted through the training so
that alvin's output better match that of
the human driver
the method for adjusting the weights is
called back propagation which i won't go
into here but welch labs has a great
series on this which i'll link to in the
description
again you can visualize the weights for
the four hidden neurons as images the
weights are initially set to be random
but as training progresses the computer
learns to pick up on certain patterns
you can see the road markings emerge in
the weights
simultaneously the output steering angle
coalesces onto the human steering angle
the computer drove the vehicle at a top
speed of around one or two kilometers
per hour
it was limited by the speed at which the
computer could perform matrix
multiplication
despite these advances artificial neural
networks still struggled with seemingly
simple tasks like telling apart cats and
dogs
and no one knew whether hardware or
software was the weak link i mean did we
have a good model of intelligence we
just needed more computer power or did
we have the wrong idea about how to make
intelligent systems altogether so
artificial intelligence experienced
another lull in the 1990s
by the mid-2000s most ai researchers
were focused on improving algorithms but
one researcher fei-fei li thought maybe
there was a different problem maybe
these artificial neural networks just
needed more data to train on so she
planned to map out the entire world of
objects from 2006 to 2009 she created
imagenet a database of 1.2 million
human-labeled images which at the time
was the largest labeled image data set
ever constructed and from 2010 to 2017
imagenet ran an annual contest the
imagenet large scale visual recognition
challenge where software programs
competed to correctly detect and
classify images images were classified
into a thousand different categories
including 90 different dog breeds a
neural network competing this
competition would have an output layer
of a thousand neurons each corresponding
to a category of object that could
appear in the image if the image
contains say a german shepherd then the
output neuron corresponding to german
shepard should have the highest
activation
unsurprisingly it turned out to be a
tough challenge one way to judge the
performance of an ai is to see how often
the five highest neuron activations do
not include the correct category this is
the so-called top five error rate in
2010 the best performer had a top five
error rate of 28.2 percent meaning that
nearly a third of the time the correct
answer was not among its top five
guesses
in 2011 the error rate of the best
performer was 25.8 percent a substantial
improvement
but the next year an artificial neural
network from the university of toronto
called alexnet blew away the competition
with a top five error rate of just
16.4 percent
what set alexnet apart was its size and
depth the network consisted of eight
layers and in total 500 000 neurons to
train alexnet 60 million weights and
biases had to be carefully adjusted
using the training database because of
all the big matrix multiplications
processing a single image required 700
million individual math operations so
training was computationally intensive
the team managed it by pioneering the
use of gpus graphical processing units
which are traditionally used for driving
displays screens so they're specialized
for fast parallel computations the
alexnet paper describing their research
is a blockbuster it's now been cited
over a hundred thousand times and it
identifies the scale of the neural
network as key to its success
it takes a lot of computation to train
and run the network but the improvement
in performance is worth it
with others following their lead the top
five error rate on the imagenet
competition plummeted in the years that
followed down to 3.6 in 2015.
that is better than human performance
the neural network that achieved this
had a hundred layers of neurons so the
future is clear we will see ever
increasing demand for ever larger neural
networks and this is a problem for
several reasons one is energy
consumption training a neural network
requires an amount of electricity
similar to the yearly consumption of
three households another issue is the
so-called von neumann bottleneck
virtually every modern digital computer
stores data in memory and then accesses
it as needed over a bus when performing
the huge matrix multiplications required
by deep neural networks most of the time
and energy goes into fetching those
weight values rather than actually doing
the computation
and finally there are the limitations of
moore's law for decades the number of
transistors on a chip has been doubling
approximately every two years but now
the size of a transistor is approaching
the size of an atom so there are some
fundamental physical challenges to
further miniaturization
so this is the perfect storm for analog
computers digital computers are reaching
their limits meanwhile neural networks
are exploding in popularity and a lot of
what they do boils down to a single task
matrix multiplication best of all neural
networks don't need the precision of
digital computers whether the neural net
is 96 or 98 confident the image contains
a chicken it doesn't really matter it's
still a chicken so slight variability in
components or conditions can be
tolerated
i went to an analog computing startup in
texas called mythic ai
here they're creating analog chips to
run neural networks and they
demonstrated several ai algorithms for
me
oh there you go see it's getting you
yeah that's fascinating the biggest use
case is augmented in virtual reality you
know if your friend is in a different
you know they're at their house and
you're at your house you can actually
render each other in the virtual world
so it needs to really quickly capture
your pose and then render it in the vr
world so hang on is this for the
metaverse then this is very yeah this is
a very metaverse
very metaverse application this is depth
estimation from just a single webcam
it's just taking this scene and then
it's doing like a heat map so if it's
bright it means it's close
if it's far away it makes it like black
now all these algorithms can be run on
digital computers but here the matrix
multiplication is actually taking place
in the analog domain to make this
possible mythic has repurposed digital
flash storage cells
normally these are used as memory to
store either a 1 or a 0. if you apply a
large positive voltage to the control
gate electrons tunnel up through an
insulating barrier and become trapped on
the floating gate remove the voltage and
the electrons can remain on the floating
gate for decades preventing the cell
from conducting current that's how you
can store either a one or a zero you can
read out the stored value by applying a
small voltage if there are electrons on
the floating gate no current flows so
that's a zero if there aren't electrons
then current does flow and that's a one
now mythic's idea is to use these cells
not as on off switches but as variable
resistors
they do this by putting a specific
number of electrons on each floating
gate instead of all or nothing the
greater the number of electrons the
higher the resistance of the channel
when you later apply a small voltage the
current that flows is equal to v over r
but you can also think of this as
voltage times conductance where
conductance is just the reciprocal of
resistance so a single flash cell can be
used to multiply two values together
voltage times conductance
so to use this to run an artificial
neural network they first write all the
weights to the flash cells as each
cell's conductance
then they input the activation values as
the voltage on the cells and the
resulting current is the product of
voltage times conductance which is
activation times weight
the cells are wired together in such a
way that the current from each
multiplication adds together completing
the matrix multiplication
so this is our our first product this
can do
25 trillion math operations per second
25 trillion 25 trillion math operations
per second and this little chip here
burning about three watts of power
how does it compare to a digital chip
the the newer digital systems can do you
know anywhere from 25 to 100 trillion
operations per second but they are big
thousand dollar systems that are
spitting out
you know 50 to 100 watts of power
obviously this isn't like an apples to
apples comparison right it's not apples
to apples i mean you know it
training those algorithms you need big
hardware like this you can just do all
sorts of stuff on the gpu but if you
specifically are doing ai workloads and
you want to deploy them you could use
this instead you can imagine them in
security cameras autonomous systems
inspection equipment for manufacturing
you know every time they make like a
frito-lay chip they inspect it with a
camera and the the bad fritos get
blown off of the conveyor belt but
they're using artificial intelligence to
spot which which fritos are good and bad
some have proposed using analog
circuitry in smart home speakers solely
to listen for the wake word like alexa
or siri they would use a lot less power
and be able to quickly and reliably turn
on the digital circuitry of the device
but you still have to deal with the
challenges of analog so for for one of
the popular networks there would be 50
sequences of matrix multipliers that
you're doing now if you did that
entirely in the analog domain by the
time it gets to the output it's just so
distorted that you don't have any result
at all so you convert it from the analog
domain back to the digital domain
send it to the next processing block and
then you convert it into the analog
domain again and that allows you to
preserve the signal
you know when rosenblatt was first
setting up his perceptron he used a
digital ibm computer
finding it too slow he built a custom
analog computer complete with variable
resistors and little motors to drive
them
you know ultimately his idea of neural
networks turned out to be right
maybe he was right about analog too
now i can't say whether analog computers
will take off the way digital did last
century but they do seem to be
better suited to a lot of the tasks that
we want computers to perform today
which is a little bit funny because i
always thought of digital as the optimal
way of processing information you know
everything from music to pictures to
video has all gone digital in the last
50 years
but maybe in a hundred years we will
look back on digital not as the end
point of information technology but as a
starting point
our brains are digital and that a neuron
either fires or it doesn't but they're
also analog
and that thinking takes place everywhere
all at once
so maybe what we need to achieve true
artificial intelligence machines that
think like us
is the power of analog
hey i learned a lot while making this
video much of it by playing with an
actual analog computer you know trying
things out for yourself is really the
best way to learn and you can do that
with this video sponsor brilliant
brilliant is a website and app that gets
you thinking deeply by engaging you in
problem solving they have a great course
on neural networks where you can test
how it works for yourself it gives you
an excellent intuition about how neural
networks can recognize numbers and
shapes and it also allows you to
experience the importance of good
training data and hidden layers to
understand why more sophisticated neural
networks work better what i love about
brilliant is it tests your knowledge as
you go the lessons are highly
interactive and they get progressively
harder as you go on and if you get stuck
there are always helpful hints for
viewers of this video brilliant is
offering the first 200 people 20 off an
annual premium subscription just go to
brilliant.org veritasium i will put that
link down in the description so i want
to thank brilliant for supporting
veritasium and i want to thank you for
watching